some 45,000 water buck graze on the
floodplains of the Gorongosa National
Park in Mozambique that's actually too
many for the grass to sustain itself
today the animals are more jumpy than
usual on the edge of the savanna
something is afoot staff from the
Southern African conservation group P
sparks are out to get them they're
setting up a huge chute with high walls
to guide the antelope into a cattle
truck as part of our rewilding process
so in total we'll move around 1,400
animals from here and which includes
water back and will also move 200
read-back this year the peace and quiet
of the bush is shattered as the hunt
begins
[Music]
a helicopter circles the group of water
buck and hurts them in the direction of
the truck
those on the ground get much closer to
the frightened animals
we got six there which which is okay I
think we're up to a total of thirty so
two-thirds of the way there we've got 50
more days 50 or 60 in the track and I'll
see the other trucks just arrived now so
our progress is going obtain
some need a little extra persuasion
today's a special day
so Werner my Berg the head of Peace
Parks has come along too he spent years
helping to prepare this initiative we
making quite a big if if the transit get
animals back to a book that has been
completely wiped out of animals there's
there's no animals at all so what
happened is in Mozambique there was a
civil war at law that over 16 years and
as a result a lot of the wildlife was
decimated and to bring back the animals
you have to come to a place like
Gorongosa National Park catch animals
and then take them all the way to new
parks that are being rehabilitation I
mean it's quite a number of those in
Mozambique that I was going through this
process of starting from scratch really
the Gorongosa National Park was one of
the first in Mozambique to be
repopulated after the Civil War ended
two decades ago the effort paid off
today there are even Lions here and the
park has enough animals to give away the
water buck now begin their journey to
the zoo novel park it's a 16 hour
non-stop ride to minimize the stress for
his precious cargo the drivers not
permitted to make longer stops unless
it's an absolute emergency like
Gorongosa the Norfolk National Park is
now to be repopulated with wild animals
transferring the water buck is a first
step in the meantime staff from peace
parks are already in the nob meeting
with Mozambican officials they're here
to discuss how to develop infrastructure
to make the park more easily accessible
to visitors bartholomew soto director
general of Mozambique's national parks
supports the project the coastlines
already developed for tourism which
should make sanam attractive to visitors
there is a national strategy that enough
fits in is that we want to rebuild all
the protected area to help the
socio-economic development of Mozambique
Mozambique has decided to opt for a
sustained
development where we improve our quality
of life but we don't destroy the
resources as yet Zenith has nothing
houses are being built for the future
Rangers and transferring the animals
alone will cost two point five million
dollars P sparks is shouldering much of
the financial burden but it's also
looking for donors the animals here will
need protection from poachers there are
people living both in and around the
park most of them impoverished farmers
or fishermen they often clear the bush
for farmland by setting fire to it the
conservationists hope to discourage that
by ensuring the park provides a source
of employment to local people
in the meantime the animals Inza na'vi
are surrounded by high electric fences
in an area of 18,000 hectares the
conservationists have come to check up
on things the animals in this area well
later populate the entire park it's
hoped as an optional part can reopen in
a few years time but first the giraffes
will be getting some new neighbors to
help rebalance the environment our
primary focus is to bring in the plains
game such as your zebra of all the beers
and in buffalo they'll they'll focus on
the long grasses and change the
ecosystem and elephants will do much the
same thing where you've got a lot of
thick bush and they'll open up the bush
for us as well they're after in about 4
or 5 years time we look at bringing in
carnivores such as lying hyena and
leopard the next day the truck carrying
the water buck finally reaches its
destination despite the long journey the
animals appear in good condition and are
soon ready to explore their new
surroundings but it's just one step on
the long road to recreating the natural
paradise that Sonam once was three wild
a landscape of this size will take time
Kruger National Park is a hundred and
ten years old this this area is a
quarter of the size of the Kruger
National Park so it will take time if
you think there's this very few animals
left to rebuild that wildlife bring it
back to the way it was that will take
anything 15 to 20 years to really get it
back to just having reinstate at the
wildlife as it was before the water buck
from Gorongosa are already settling into
their new home over the next few years
they'll be joined by some 7500 animals
from other African parks and so
gradually Sonam will come back to life